did you know that natural skincare can
be really bad for babies they can
potentially cause food allergies when
babies are born their brand new immune
systems need to learn what's safe and
what's dangerous when it learns the
wrong thing and thinks peanuts need to
be attacked that's an allergic reaction
and it can be really dangerous well when
a fresh young immune system meets a
small amount of something going through
the skin especially in flame skin it's
more likely to learn that it's dangerous
but when it meets it in a large amount
through the digestive system it's more
likely to learn that it's safe this is
the Dual allergen exposure hypothesis
and it's become pretty widely accepted
with lots of evidence building over the
last 20 years it's more of a problem
when the Skin Barrier is leaky and
inflamed like with eczema or under a
nappy one in five babies have eczema
it's happened to adults with eczema 2.
there's examples with goat's milk wheat
corn almond oats the allergens are
protein so if it's a really purified
less natural ingredient it's not as much
of a risk